hey youtubers is charlie thank you
everyone that submitted questions for
this week's flash arrow QA there was
also a ton of TV shows that got picked
up you know both DC and Marvel so I'll
try to address a little bit of that
during this Q&A but this is mostly going
to be flash arrow stuff because of the
finales there's been a lot of questions
about what the timeline is because the
episodes are out of sync what I think
the intention is is that episode 22 of
the flash is supposed to take place in
the timeline after episode 23 the finale
of arrow but because the flash airs
first during the week is just a little
wonky episode 23 is the flash finale
that will happen in two weeks so there
are two more episodes of the flash one
more episode of arrow and then we'll get
the spin-off trailer after the last
episode of the flash just careful for
spoilers if you haven't seen this week's
episodes yet so here we go questions
Tristan asks if Eddie never married iris
then how did he marry because he had to
have a kid with someone if he didn't
Harrison wells wouldn't be born well
presumably he just married someone else
just some other random girl the show has
changed the comic book characters just a
little bit in the comics when we meet a
labar Thawne most of what we know about
his family is his nuclear family like
the family from the 25th century those
are the Thawne family members that we do
meet but not in a way that would explain
what the TV show is doing like you have
cobalt blue and then you have Bart Allen
who's also from the future but those are
really some of the only other big
thawne's that we run into of all the
people coming back and season two I
definitely think Rick cos net the actor
is coming back so i think we'll continue
to explore his family's lineage through
his character but we will see like the
future a abarth on you remember the guy
from episode 17 the true heir barth on
we'll see him again probably in a
flashback question number two mr. asks
what if Eiling becomes the team leader
of flash in season two sarcastic yeah
that would be like darkest timeline
flash like if they if they change
history and suddenly it becomes really
depressing and dark everybody comes back
with like alternate universe Star Trek
goatees it'd be like team flash going
crime syndicate Eiling seems like one of
those antagonistic characters that's
technically not a villain that they'll
probably keep bringing back in grata
sodes so I think he'll still be a big
part of season two but I don't think
he's ever going to rise
above the level of guest actor next
question ticky toddy asks I think AO
bard was lying to Eddie about him not
being important in the lineage of the
thawne's so you think you think he's
like trying to bait him into doing
something it you know trying to seed a
self-fulfilling prophecy that's totally
possible we don't really know enough
about the original timeline before the
reverse-flash started changing things to
say the show does a pretty good job of
explaining its internal logic so you
know whatever they want us to think
they'll show it on screen there is
subtext in the show and there are a few
mysteries but big things like that they
do explain pretty well cue evil villain
monologuing if you think about it if a
labar Thawne were really smart he
wouldn't tell anybody what his plan is
but he seems like he really enjoys
talking about himself the character in
the comics is really full of himself so
you can see why the show is having fun
with that I'm a genius where I come from
imagine how smart that makes me here
next question ramina asks how come STAR
Labs has no security and iris can just
walk in anytime she wants so yeah that's
a good question and a lot of people are
asking how could she could just walk in
and surprise them like that I think the
easiest answer is is the team flash-
Harrison wells just isn't that great yet
as if there's a lot of simple mistakes
that they make just because they don't
have experience and running a superhero
team this first season is about them
learning to take things more seriously
remember the arrow crossover whenever
they were in the foundry in the bar over
drinks the writers did this good job of
juxtaposing what was going on on aero vs
what was going on flash caitlin snow had
this comment where she was like we've
all been treating this like a game so
far we give our villains funny comic
book names and Roy is just like sitting
there sulking in his drink about how
terrible everything is in Starling
that's just a reflection of the tone of
both shows I mean the flash is made to
be lighter a little bit more comedic but
it's very true Caitlin Barry Cisco just
don't take things quite as seriously as
you would see and say like a future
Justice League movie next question QEW
asks Ray Palmer could buy STAR Labs
willsez known for years that when we're
together he'll eventually leave he might
have left a will so you're talking about
like who is going to take over ownership
of STAR Labs when season two starts STAR
Labs has been around for at least the
last
you know 12 to 13 14 years Mary's mom
was murdered about 15 years ago and
within about a year that eobard thawne
became Harrison wells and started
building the particle accelerator he
would have needed to amass a ton of
funding for that so he probably got a
ton of funding from outside sources and
then he probably found a way to profit
from all the technology that they were
building so there probably is some sort
of like succession plan built in because
he would have had to do that because of
all the funding he had to secure its
really one of those questions that we
have to ask the writers because this
sounds like one of those things that
they haven't quite figured out yet
there's also the question as to whether
or not they're gonna fill the hole that
Harrison wells that Tom Cavanagh is
gonna leave in the cast if he leaves at
all when they were sitting on the
treadmill Barry was like hey you know we
don't need wells we can do this just the
three of us you know in Caitlin was like
well it was actually the four of us that
did it talking about iris so barring any
additional cast members that they bring
in to STAR Labs I think it's just gonna
be those characters next season running
things on their own next question the
Batman asks will Grodd be the season two
main villain the only reason I don't
think he's going to be the ultimate big
bad it's just because those characters
have to be on screen a lot and I think
it'd be really expensive for them to try
to do that he'll probably have a really
big role like I mean he'll still be a
really big character in season two but
until the cost of technology comes down
to a certain point I think it's really
hard to have a character as big as they
need to be to be the big bat you know to
be on screen for many many episodes
without it being super cheap so it'll
still probably a human actor what I'm
really hoping is is that Eddie turns
into the season 2 villain but it might
be too premature for that that might be
like a season 3 thing next question Ken
dog says Roy's identity in the motor
pool was changed to Jason and I just
immediately thought of Jason Todd yeah I
think it you know you could consider
that a brief easter egg for Jason Todd I
think Roy's relationship with team arrow
is going to be a lot like the red hoods
relationship with Batman like in the
context of the arrow universe Roy's got
to go off on his own unlike a sojourn
still being a superhero and occasionally
crossing paths with team arrow in the
future Colton Haynes is pursuing his
film career right now so what's probably
gonna happen is is you'll see him pop up
in a couple episodes next season you
know maybe one maybe two or at least by
season five when he left he said he was
totally happy to come back but but a lot
of that just depends on what his skin
but the jason todd easter egg isn't an
indication that he is going to become
the red hood or anything like that it's
just like a fun wink at the audience
next question Parker asks they better
develop felicity she's so annoying in
her character has regressed a lot this
season yet you know one of the problems
with shows is when you have a cast this
big you can only spend so much time
developing a certain number of
characters there's always going to be
somebody that gets left in the lurch
that's what I think this scene with Ray
Palmer is all about making Felicity the
new owner and CEO of Palmer tech there's
also a lot of theories that the main
villain Damien dark of season four is
going to be Felicity's father they'd be
a really easy way for the arrow writers
to leave themselves a strong Felicity
foundation to build a really good story
on what I'd really like to see is
Felicity build herself some tech but I
don't know that that's part of the
character so most of the time the
solutions that she comes up with on her
own are peaceful solutions like she
still takes villains down but in a very
non violent way the best example of that
is with Wi-Fi from last season
next question ama desks when will arrow
season 4 in the flash season 2 air they
haven't confirmed anything yet but by
all accounts it'll be about the exact
same time as season 3 and season one of
the flash aired just in general the
schedules going to be the same they were
they were both October premieres what
might happen is they might get bumped
forward by a week or bump back by a week
but it'll still be in October it'll air
till December then we'll go on break
come back in January the spin-off is
supposed to premiere sometime in January
that's also unconfirmed if they do have
three shows on at the same time what I'm
expecting is is that they'll all air on
different nights like flash on Tuesday
arrow on Wednesday and legends of
tomorrow on another day right now I feel
like the CW is Thursday night
programming just isn't quite as strong
as its Tuesday Wednesday programming so
thursday right now is my top choice that
way it wouldn't be competing with Gotham
because it's also probably to be like a
p.m. show thank you so much everyone for
asking questions these are always a ton
of fun to do next week is actually going
to be like the CW upfront so we'll
probably get a lot more information
about the spin-off series you know what
the cast is going to be doing when
they're going to air it that's really
the biggest question is like what day is
it going to start on
just going down the list here are the
shows that got renewed I'm also all
include the Marvel once in here too we
got super girl that was picked up for
series they didn't announce a premiere
date yet it'll be on CBS they picked up
legends of tomorrow of course that's
going straight to series on CW then in
the Marvel Universe agent Carter and
agents of shield were both picked up for
another season the only superhero shows
that have been canceled so far are
Constantine they just confirmed
Constantine's canceled on NBC it could
go to another network and ABC did not
pick up the agents of shield spinoff
series the one that was supposed to be
about mockingbird so next week arrow
finale and rogue prison break be sure to
subscribe to get those videos don't
worry there's a lot of fun flash ring
stuff that we have to talk about next
week but I want to wait till after the
episode airs just to give you guys a
little tease something to get excited
about there are at least three rings on
the flash that are going to be in the
next two episodes see if you can guess
what all the three rings are please be
sure to use spoiler tags so while you
guys wait for all that stuff to post you
can click here for this week's flash
trailer and you can click here to learn
all about the cast of Captain America
Civil War some you know minor age of
Ultron spoilers you guys haven't seen
age of Ultron yet thank you so much
watching everybody let's high five I'll
see you guys tomorrow
you